-Now, I thought I'd share some
of my favorite #WeddingFai
responses from you guys.
This first one is
from @cjdoran11.
She says, "One of our friend
was dancing
with a middle-age friend
of the family.
He tied his tie around her head.
When he pulled it off,
her wig came off with it."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oops.
-This one's
from Hannah Sivongsak.
[Suh-ve-nock]
Sah-ven-ock.
Hannah Sah-ven-ock.
[ Laughter ]
-Hannah Sah-ven-ock.
-She says, "My husband
is not a drinker,
but decided to do vodka shot
with practically everyone
at the wedding.
He needed to be brought
up to the hotel room
on a luggage cart.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh, wow!
-That's bad.
-I got a lotta baggage, baby
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This one's
from @GabiBracco.
She says, "The DJ
played the wrong song
for the couple's first dance
Instead of the U2 track
they asked for,
he played "I Still Haven't
Found What I'm Looking For."
[ Laughter ]
No, he has!
-No!
-They found what they're
looking for.
Please shut this off.
Oh, my God.
This one's from @clarac91.
She says, "My black dress
ripped at a wedding
and I used a black Sharpie
to color in my thigh
so you couldn't tell."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah!
-No, that's called thinkin'.
[ Applause continues ]
-I have a feeling
that you could still tell.
-Well.
[ Laughter ]
-This one's
from @AnnieHowington.
She said, "Our photographe
[laughing] Photoshopped Jesu
into our wedding photo."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Look at this.
[ Cheering ]
I mean, we're religious,
but we didn't witness a miracle.
I mean, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Can you believe this?
-Yeah. And the wedding
never ran out of wine.
-No.
-It was unbelievable.
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's from @EtEs97.
[Ee-tez]
She said, "We requested a bu
to transport the seniors
in the family to the venue
It showed up fully loaded
with a stripper pole
and disco lights."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[as senior]
Alright, there!
Here we go.
[ Vuvuzela blows ]
Here comes Alum!
♪♪♪♪
-[Chuckling]
-Next up, Metamucil!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
Ensure!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
AARP!
[ Vuvuzela blows ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Can't think of another one
-I was looking over there.
-Yeah.
-Try it again.
Try it again.
-Yeah. Do one more.
♪♪♪♪
-Me?
-Yeah, you.
Okay.
Give it up for...false teeth
[ Vuvuzela blows ]
[ Laughter ]
Do you have another one?
I can't think of another -
-Another elderly product?
-Yeah.
-Ovaltine?
-Geritol's good.
-Give it up for Geritol.
-Oh, Geritol's a good one.
-Geritol's good.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
-Put your hands together for..
Geritol!
[ Vuvuzela blows ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
Oh, the tennis balls are off
The tennis balls are off!
[ Laughter ]
Here comes Centrum Silver!
Yeah!
-This last one is
from @thebaziness.
He says, "I tried to re-create
the lift from 'Dirty Dancing.'
I cracked my wife's rib."
[ Audience oohing ]
There you have it,
those are the
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to
thetonightshow.com/hashtags.